Good afternoon.
My name is TV wrong.
I'm going to be the faculty for
introduction to data system.
Alright.
And I'll I think we will start
now I am seeing the.
Yes, uh, good evening to
everyone.
And what we will do is let's get
started with the subject.
And for right now I have not
enabled your mic, but I'll be
doing it pretty soon.
Maybe in 10 minutes or so.
Uh, OK, I'm seeing two people,
Janakiraman and VIJAYALAKSHMI in
the lobby.
I'm I'm not sure I should be.
Uh, what is the reason why they
had to come with some ID which
is not bits ID?
Uh, So what?
I'm going to do is.
I'm I'm denying the entry for
the time being.
I I think I cannot because our
administration is very clear
that everybody should log in
with the the Google ID that BITS
provides to you.
OK, so let's get.
So today we will be really doing
an introduction to the course
and in a way it's an
introduction to the program
because you know.
I do you know the program is all
about data science, and in this
semester, this course is going
to tell you about the basics of
data science so that you are
ready to receive the advanced
content with respect to the data
science.
OK, what is the I?
I'm not sure what is the concept
of system not working because it
is a there are people with the
access issues.
OK.
Uh, just give me one minute.
Give me one minute.
Let me check with the
administration whether this is
OK for me to allow for the first
session or because I do not want
to do something which is which
is clearly denied or forbidden
for the participants.
So I'm putting you people on me.
OK, OK.
I I'm not sure if the student
VIJAYALAKSHMI is available in
conversation with anyone of you.
You can ask her or him to Join
Now because what administration
is saying is that yes, there are
some people who are having some
ID issues.
The in the sense that their
ideas have been set up very
late, so it is possible that the
the MS Teams is denying them
access using.
So I'm willing to allow that so.
So if there are some some of
your friends who want to join?
Uh only.
Only the people for whom the IDs
are not set up.
So you may inform them.
And this is this exception I'm
told is only for this session
because they are aware of the
technical matters.
OK, let's get started with the
subject.
So these are the course
objectives and the let me put it
in presentation mode.
All right, help you understand
the role of data science, aren't
it?
And help you understand the
stages in data science project
and familiarize you with the
processes, tools, technologies
and appreciate things like
several techniques such as
visualization, storytelling and
understand the techniques.
In fact, we will spend half the
time studying the techniques for
techniques for real world data
and data analytics and
discovering the intelligent,
interesting patterns.
So this is where we will spend
most of time.
So our intent is that you learn
how to discover.
Interesting.
Patterns.
That are he then in the date.
And these are the textbooks and
the and I encourage you that you
own at least T1 or T4 if
possible.
And if you are someone who is
deep in the subject, who is
working on many of these
methods, all these books are
good for you.
Alright.
And the structure of the course
is the Today we will be focusing
on fundamentals and then we will
be spending about four or five
sessions depending on the pace
at which we go in looking at the
data descriptions.
Data preprocessing.
And then we will be spending
significant amount of time that
is about about 8 sessions is
planned, 8 sessions is planned.
On deep patterns.
And we will look briefly into
what is the meaning of a pattern
called Classification
Association cluster anomaly.
So we will look at them in maybe
after half hour and we will
spend some time that after you
discover the pattern, how do you
tell the story?
And then towards the end, we
will look at what are the ethics
for data science.
And the evaluation is in the
form of two quizzes with the 10%
marks overall, then two
assignments with the 20% Marks
and then mid semester and
comprehensive examinations with
70%.
And the calendar and the
schedule will be announced the
dates.
Will be announced.
In the canvas.
OK, so I hope I hope we is so
far uneventful.
It is clear.
OK, someone has a question.
Is the mid semester closed book
and or openbook?
I believe mid semester meant to
be open closed book and end
semester is for is an open book.
Uh, yes, Mr that mendra should
my you are allowed to carry the
lecture notes to the open book
examination.
Uh and assignment will be in
groups.
Mr Shamshad is asking assignment
will be in the groups and the
group formation we will
announce.
So so that you Please wait for
that.
So first we will go with the you
defining what is data science.
So we are taking the definition
from one of the reputed
organization and in any case I
the the you know there are there
are so many words in our
industry and there is no
authority to define those words
or to interpret the words.
So in that sense, you need to
live with the little bit of
interpretation element within
any of these definitions that we
talk about.
So we have so.
So it makes sense that we take
it from a reputed vendor.
Alright.
And this is talking about
uncovering actionable insights
hidden in the data.
And why do we want to discover
the actionable insights they
help with the decision making
and planning?
And what is involved in data
science?
It will involve math and stats,
so programming and let me put it
along with this though, though
the definition does not put it,
so let me include algos or or
algorithms.
OK, so so along the programming.
The programming requires
algorithms, then understanding
the analytics and then
artificial intelligence and
machine learning along with
subject matter expertise.
Right.
And why is it that we need to
study data science?
I think we will.
We will be keeping on looking at
the reason why we should be
doing it, but maybe we can take
a few minutes to have a
conversation about why is it
that data science required, so
maybe I'll start with.
Yeah, I'll I think it's an
opportune time for me to unmute
you people for some time.
So I'm sorry, this is the.
This is the participants.
I'm allowing mic OK so so we
will spend few minutes
understanding why is it that
data science required and
possibly this will answer some
of the questions that we address
as we go along.
OK.
Mr Suhail Ganesh is saying is
better decisions alright?
Alright.
But but how is the?
How is it helping?
I mean, is there something that
OK now let us let us go to some
some small note that it's here,
this is 2008.
So before 2008, what people not
making decisions?
Hello.
Or is it that that data
scientist designation is heard
Ohh Sir, am I audible?
of only last decade?
And.
So does it mean that people were
not making decisions before
that?
OK, there are.
Hello.
Am I audible?
There are few things that we
need.
OK, right.
You are right, it's a insights.
So.
So we will look at maybe an
example that helps you
understand.
So so now now there is suppose
that suppose that there is a
data which is organized in
relational database and then
what do you what do you what can
you do?
You can write SQL queries right?
You can write SQL queries.
You can create aggregates.
OK, so far so good.
So now let us say we are talking
about God, EE, Automobile
Excuse me, Sir, but can you
listen to me?
company.
Alright, a automobile company
that is, that is trying to are
trying to decide on in fact it
needs it needs a lot of these
aggregates because the decision
maker wants to know what is the
volume of sale in the East June
and what is the percentage
increase in this month compared
to last month.
What is the percentage change in
this month compared to the same
month last year?
So they will be interested in
many, many aggregates which are
referred as OEP online.
Analytical processes.
So once again, can you, uh, can
you listen to us?
OK, so so they are able to do
that and now they also they also
possibly want to know certain
things.
For example, they may want to
know what is the likelihood of
sales next year.
So now it is a.
We can always think in terms of
uh, think in terms of a very
simple extrapolation.
So the sales.
Alright, sales and then here.
So what we know is that sales in
this year sales in this year and
Hello, Rao Sir.
Are you are you able to hear us
browser? Hello.
sales in this year.
So we have certain points.
Hello.
So we want to know what is the
sales for this year.
Am I audible to anyone?
So I think it is not very
difficult for them that use this
You're audible, but I think,
Sir, can't hear you.
Yeah, yeah, invertible.
Ohh.
data and do an extrapolation and
say that we can possibly expect
OK.
the sales to be in this year so
far.
Thank you.
Thank you for confirmation.
So now you can say that can we
do it with the aggregations and
queries?
And but using some statistical
functions we should be able to
do and to this extent simple
extrapolation or linear
extrapolation and forecast is
not do.
It is also data scientists to do
that forecasting.
So we are not so much concerned
about uh, this this was this
salt are possibly possibly it
was it can be done.
So now let us look at another
data.
So we have data saying that, uh,
the age.
Of buyer.
And then color of car.
So we have an interesting we
have a pattern, age of the buyer
is 30.
So bought a red car.
And 35 blue card, let us say,
let us simplify the problem.
There are only two colors that
they sell, red color or blue
color.
Ohk.
OK.
You lick me.
Lick me.
Be little more careful.
Alright, OK so.
No, no.
Look at this data.
I have got the age of the buyer
and color of the car.
And you are all unmuted, so
somebody can speak out if you
want to say something.
Do you want to say anything
about this data?
Yeah, I am.
Is are you able to hear us?
Anybody wants to say anything?
I you are all unmuted so if you
want to speak you can speak.
Are you are you able to hear us?
Ah, OK OK.
I need to I OK.
Please speak now.
Are you able to hear us?
How do you able?
Yes, I'm able to hear you now.
I think I have put my speaker on
mute for some time.
Yeah.
I'm sorry about that.
Yes, no problem.
Please go ahead.
Mr Souda, please go ahead, Mr.
Yeah.
So Rao, Sir.
Just you know, before that I
just trying to understand that
how we are going to get books
actually you know you have not
you know shared this
information, do we are we
getting PDF file or we need to
buy the book.
You need to.
OK.
OK, let me let me put it this
way.
Let me put it this way.
Uh, the authors of the books
want you to buy the books, and I
have my own copies of books.
So now the question is how you
want to get the books is not.
I'm not in a position to get
tell anybody anything in Mr
South of have I answered your
question.
Yes, you answered my question.
Thank you, Rao, Sir.
Thank you. OK.
OK.
Other people who are who have
missed I whom I could not hear
please speak.
Mr Amit Chaudhary, you raised
your hand.
Do you want to say something?
And swaroopa katiki, you also
raised the hand you want to say
something.
Yes, you can speak.
I I yeah, I mean the site.
So I just wanted to know like I
missed one thing when we were
Yes, Mr Amit, go ahead.
describing like the you see EC2
and EC3 and the media and the
final semester final exam.
So will it be open book or close
book?
The final examination will be
open book.
And the meat one will be.
Closed book.
OK. Thanks.
OK, other people who have got
the questions.
Right, so Karthik here I'm.
I'm just repeating the same
question for books, right?
You recommended T1 and T4 right
to start with.
Is that right?
See, The thing is that the most
of the algorithms that we study
will be from either T1 or T4, so
that is why I was trying to say
OK.
that at least have one of that
book because you will be able to
study the details of the
algorithm and maybe the authors
explanation that may be better
than my explanation.
So that is that is the reason
why I was saying T1T4.
OK.
But there is no other reason
but.
But it's still, we had to go
with T2 and 3T3 as well, right?
No, no.
Yes, yes.
Was told.
T2T3T3 will be covered, but then
one is about about the
presentation and one is about
overview of data science.
So I welcome you to own those
books too, but the algorithms
God.
will be covered from T1 and T.
Thank you.
So Sir, I open.
You want it?
I need to buy both.
Do you one and T4?
Mr.
Harrigal, can you repeat the
question?
Yeah, anyone is fine or we need
to buy both the T1 and T4.
Yes, actually both these authors
are competitive in the market in
the sense that they they.
So either of them should be good
but but then if you are, if you
OK. Thank.
are really deeply interested in,
maybe you can buy both because
they're not expensive books.
So the books that we are
prescribing are all within
within ₹1000 less than ₹1000.
So maybe 607 hundred kind of
things.
Thank you.
So umm, Sir I one question.
So in terms of in finding
insights and all business
intelligence is always there and
quite sometimes there are
multiple tools to go through the
data raw data and convert it in
information and more useful
thing, right.
So even the data science you're
describing it, it also helps us
to find the insights of the
data, right.
So are we talking about
predictive analytics, which is
Right.
specific to data science or
finding insights is always there
in the system without even
before the data science.
When AM alarm tonight using any
BI tools and all it's.
OK. Right.
Right, right.
So, so fine, Mr VENKATRAMAN.
I think the question will be I I
think you are knowledgeable
enough that I I don't need to
give you answer because there is
I do not have much better answer
but but then as we discussed so
maybe at some other point we can
bring up.
So it's not really that the data
science term was introduced in
10 years back or became popular,
but then some of the techniques
existed even before that.
So I agree with that.
But anyway, if?
Umm.
Sure.
Thank you. Thanks.
Yeah alright any.
That this one last question
regarding the motor mode of the
exams.
When you say offline online and
you know the midterms and then
teams, these are all we go to an
exam center and take or you will
we can we have an online link
and if it is online look how
Uh.
See, that is.
That is something.
will we enforce those.
Please, Please wait for the
announcement from the
administration because that will
not apply to only one subject
OK.
because so see generally that is
something that is related to all
the subjects.
So let us wait for this, because
I they they maybe see
Alright.
previously.
I I can tell you only the
history.
So till 2019 we used to have all
these examinations in
examination centers and 2020, we
started having once the epidemic
OK.
started, all these examinations
became online and now now we
have we have freedom to conduct
in either way.
So, but Please wait for the
announcement from the
administration.
This is decided by the
administration.
Thank.
Thank you for that. Yeah.
OK, Mr Harikrishnan is saying,
what is the meaning of open book
open book means that you can
have the textbook and print outs
of the slides and print and the
notes etcetera with you.
Is that good enough?
Yes, Sir.
And one more question is the
Exama pen and paper or an
online?
I mean in the center.
Ohh that we will announce
because there is some discussion
going on but till now it is
largely pen and paper.
After you write it on pen, you
actually you send the picture to
So.
the.
You upload the picture.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
So one more question, so mute
will you solve any use case like
class screen regression using
Python in this course?
Uh, as we go along short, we
will have some sessions or some
interaction and some guidelines
or some support with respect to
Python, but then Python itself
will not be the main topic
because we the the subject is
not necessarily only for Python
programs though.
Though let me clarify that the M
tech data science students need
to know Python because all the
assignments in all these objects
will be based on Python.
But so in that sense, you need
to know the Python, but then
these the course itself.
The LECTURES itself will have
nothing to do with Python And
and we will give you possibly
some hints or some help with
respect to demonstrating
something's in Python.
And then specific so would we
have any lab in this course as
well?
It's not.
See, The thing is there will be
some tutorials with some more
help in regarding Python will be
given and for the sake of
assignments you may have to
write Python code.
Sure. Thanks.
Yes, OK.
There are no questions.
So now I want you to speak, but
speak on what you are seeing on
Yeah, more.
this slide.
More car cars are sealed.
Sold are blue and younger people
are preferring red color than
OK.
blue.
OK.
OK, Mr Reviendra Kumar Singh,
that is good.
Younger people are preferring
red color over blue color.
OK.
So that is that is good.
So now, now let us let us go
back.
Let us go back to let us go back
to what is here.
So if a CEO of the automobile
company wants to know how many
cars were sold in the Western
region in the second quarter of
202324, so be information
systems or who you've ever have
to promptly give the CEO
accurate data that data has to
be definitive.
So they have to say that model
M1V sold 10,434 cars and how
much profit did we make on those
cars?
We have made 25 crores, 50,000
something something some number
exact number they have to give.
So there aren't definitive
answers that are expected from
some part of the data, but then
there is a lot of data in which
we are not getting definitive
answers.
But then we are seeing some
patterns and then what is the
nature of these patterns?
These patterns have an
interesting property.
These are key.
These are approximate.
And these are probabilistic.
So based on this, uh, it's one
of you have correctly said that
younger people seem to have a
tendency to buy red cars, while
the people with the higher age
have seemed to be having a
tendency to buy blue cars.
But then that data is not
definitive.
So there is a person with the
age of 35 is buying red car.
The person with the ease of 36
by sorry, age of 35 is buying
blue car.
The person with the age of 36 is
buying a red car, but then that
does not mean that that does not
mean that the pattern itself is
wrong.
The pattern is anyway
approximate and many times we
discover the pattern with a
level of accuracy that is less
than 100%.
Sometimes we are happy to find
70% accurate pattern and now how
to measure the accuracy?
Let's not jump that far.
So we will, we will for each
pattern we are going to see what
is the level of quality of the
pattern and then how to compare
the quality of multiple patterns
so that we are going to see as
we go.
So now is this is this answer
definitive?
Somebody is walking in with the
age of 37.
What color of the car will the
person buy?
Probably blue.
No.
Yeah, possibly blue, possibly
blue.
So that is a that is just a
possible that it is likelihood.
But if that person asks for red
car, we are going to give the
person red car, right?
So so there is, yeah.
Of course, yes.
So the point is that so anytime
somebody may walk in with the
age of 21 and ask for blue car
and buy it, and the person with
65 may come in and say that by
red card for whatever reasons
they we don't need to find the
reasons that person may be
buying for granddaughter, that's
fine.
But the person walks in for at
65 and buys erect card.
We are going to give.
So now the point is that this is
not a definitive answer.
So will the person buy red car
or green card blue card?
But then it helps.
Suppose that suppose that the
manufacturer wants to know how
should I maintain inventory.
So in that case it is possible
that one of our algorithm is
possibly going to help that
person saying what is the, what
is the indicative?
Uh.
A shade of for based on the heat
and what is the indicative
preferences for based on the
ease or based on income based
on.
In fact, we have taken a very,
very simple one dimensional data
and one dimensional 1
dimensional glass.
We can call that as a class, so
that is because this is an
interesting attribute.
This is going to determine
something for our decision
making.
So.
So the point is that it is going
to help us.
So now, now what we are saying
is that the BI mostly focused on
this.
But I'm not seeing that BI only
focused on this BI, possibly
also focused on something
related.
What is on the right side?
But it is the data science which
started more incorporating lot
of probability and lot of
complex algorithms in order to
draw back and so for example for
example we have elections going
for several states right now.
So for elections, obviously
there are, there are everybody
who is interested in the results
of election.
Of course, even before the
results come.
That is why that is what our in
curiosity is a lot more before
the elections happen.
Then, after the elections are
over anyway, we'll get to know
the results.
So our curiosity is a lot more
about who is going to win the
elections.
So now how can we learn the
election results or how can we
predict the election results
without before the elections
happen?
Maybe somebody wants to tell so
that is all data science and
then there are many data
science.
Who are presently working or
helping each political party
with respect to that.
So that somebody wants to say
anything about it.
How are they going to do that?
Sentiment of sentiment can be
starting point.
I want the.
Uh yes, Mr Aditya Singh.
Can you repeat that?
That K sentiment of the crowd we
got regarding the parties
That sentiment of the crowd we
got regarding all the parties
Same to me.
can just start.
OK, same timing.
sentiment about that.
Same comment about that, yes,
yes, yes.
Yeah.
Ohh there is something already
called approval rate which we
Yes, OK.
always get before the elections
and everything.
Yes, OK.
OK, so now maybe maybe is that
all approval ratings sentiment,
do they do you think that those
people do it in such a simple
way in one dimensional plane?
They will most probably look at
the dimension.
No, no, no, no.
Just maybe, maybe let me also
give you some hints.
In each area has the uh crowd.
Uh crowds a set of attributes
regarding the crowd and the
whatever the party is projecting
itself in that area based on
that data which they collect
from that area, they'll present
themselves accordingly to the
public.
So data personalization on the.
You're right, right that is
correct.
That is correct.
Yes, Mr Vertica, I fully agree
with you.
So they consider many
attributes.
For example, it is possible that
some political parties are
favorite of factory workers and
some political party is a
favorite of agriculture or
laborers, and some political
party may be a favorite of rich
farmers and some political party
is a favorite of professionals.
So it is the, it is the job of
those analysts who are working
for political parties.
In order to analyze constituency
by constituency, some political
parties may be preferred by
gender, so it is possible that
the for some reason some people
of some gender may prefer
females, may prefer certain
political party and so it is
always possible.
And similarly, senior citizens
may prefer some political party
because of various regions.
So now the point is that you
need to consider many attributes
before and then you also need to
do a division of the population
as per.
Ohh the this is referred as
demographic analysis and then
based on that and then further
you need to see how is the
preference among the various
categories based on demographic
parameters.
The preferences among the people
and so on.
So there can be more than that,
but then fine, we will leave it
because, for example, you may
talk about ideology, but we'll
let's not get into that.
So.
So the point is that so now here
we are talking about purely data
science.
There is really nothing like
business intelligence, which is
very often definitive, and
sometimes the business
intelligence also have
extrapolating content in that.
But the data science is mostly
about creating models whereby
you can get probably
approximately correct answers,
which is, you know pretty well
that when the elections happen,
there will be at least 20
agencies.
All of them have a lot of data
scientists and they have.
They spent crores of rupees in
analyzing the voter preferences
and immediately after the
elections are over, they're
going to publish the no data
they they don't know, they don't
know findings based on various
studies that they had done.
And you know that some of them
go wrong and some of them go
right.
So this is because what they are
doing is probably approximately
correct.
It is not a definitive answer
because they do not have the
reach to reach 150 crore people.
So all they can do is that they
will reach out to million people
or at most million people, or
maybe 100,000 people, and the
quality of the analysis depends
on the attributes that they
considered and so on.
So now does the.
Does it help you understand the
Mr VENKATRAMAN army In Sync?
That data science has some
attributes that did.
Something.
Yeah.
So which makes it different from
so the business intelligence
though the business intelligence
also there is really no
definition saying that business
intelligence should stop here or
data science should start from
here.
But then what we know is that it
is largely associated with
probabilistic, so statistics are
strongly associated with the our
data science.
That is because our answers are
very often.
Consider the probabilities.
OK so so I will proceed little
further.
And and let me lick me.
Proceed.
I think I have been at the
beginning so so this diagram is
possibly self explanatory.
Anyway, it is proposed by in
website.
So this is uh, and then you can
see that from this diagram there
is a significant overlap between
the areas of DS, ML and EI.
So when we talk about data
science, we are talking about
these are representing these are
representing the various
algorithms.
And machine learning is a
mechanism whereby we try to
solve many of the problems in
data science, not necessarily
that every problem has 200% and
needs to have a machine
learning.
So we can possibly do many of
the data preparation tasks and
many statistics.
You may say that statistics is
not really machine learning,
though it may look somewhat
similar in the sense that may
give some results with some
accuracy or some level of
confidence and and then
visualization experimentation.
These are all parts of data
science.
Not, but then they do not
involve really machine learning
and machine learning is is going
to help us in creating many of
the algorithms are based on
machine learning.
So those algorithms help the
machine understand the data and
support us, and then when we are
talking about artificial
intelligence.
So artificial intelligence also
has a strong element, which is,
which is also, which also
incorporates machine learning.
Significantly.
Uh and uh.
Data science is if we look at if
you look at, uh, the machine
learning, OK, maybe maybe we'll
let me put often it is
supervised.
And unsupervised.
Waste.
These are the types of machine
learning which we deal with very
often, and maybe it can also be
a semi supervised and machine
learning can also have and it
seldom we deal with what is
known as a reinforcement
learning.
It's not so much valuable in
trying to understand the data of
an organization.
But then, reinforcement learning
can be very valuable if you want
to build a game.
Suppose that you want to build a
a game where where it is going
to it can play with another
machine or it can play with a
human.
Or if you want to teach it to
some robotics, for example, how
to work through a hazardous
area.
So in such cases we want to work
with a form of a machine
learning which is known as a
reinforcement.
I hope this explains reasonably,
and let's look at the relation
between data science and machine
learning from one of the most
famous authors of machine
learning books called Tom
Mitchell.
And this is probably self
explanatory.
So all we are saying is that we
say that the machine is learning
if machine gains experience and
starts performing task with
greater performance.
So that is so we have an element
of a task experience and
performance.
Then we say that we have trained
a machine to perform the task
better.
So then we say that machine
learning has happened.
And hobbies machine learning
different from a traditional
programming in a traditional
programming that all of you may
be familiar, we have a data that
we want to process and we have a
program in the logic.
So.
So what is the for?
What is the?
Let us look at let us look at
this output.
So so let us take a bank
example.
So we are saying that balance.
And then interest rates?
And uh calculations in
algorithms.
And then accrual.
Of interest.
Two accounts, so this is a case
of a traditional programming.
So now, now let us say, let us
say we are saying that we have
the bank has many products.
Bank has many products.
We are taking the bank example
and we have the the users or
users or buyers of those
products, so demographics.
Of customers.
Yielding the products.
And in model.
2.
Cross sell.
Perfect.
Does it?
Does it explain what is the
difference between a traditional
programming and machine learn?
So here we are building we are
we have a data and from the data
and then the possibly the the
type of people who have bought
the products.
So we what we are able to do is
that we are able to generate a
model that is going to help us
in promoting the products in
future.
But in this case what we had
done in a traditional
programming is we have done the
calculations.
Necessity for our purpose.
And the types of ML.
Can be supervised.
So given training data, we are
going to, we are going to get,
we are going to generate a model
that is going to that is going
to help us in doing a task which
is known as a classification.
So we are, we are going to
define that as we go along, OK.
And unsupervised, unsupervised
is that we have a lot of
training data and can we
discover.
She didn't patterns.
And then there can be something
in between.
So we have a small amount of
training training data with
class labels or outputs and a
lot of training data without any
labels.
So in that case, we can combine
the top two algorithms to
generate insights.
Can you give a real life example
for supervised and unsupervised
learning?
Yes, yes, A is it fine if I do
that after 10-15 minutes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, sure.
Sure, sure.
OK, alright.
And then a reinforcement
learning is an example where we
are training the machine to
drive a car.
So we are telling that if you,
if you if you are meeting in, so
if you go very close to another
vehicle, there is a penalty or
or so.
So that the machine needs to
recognize and the machine goes
at a steady speed.
Then there is a reward.
And so on.
So similarly for a game.
So suppose that it's a
competitive game like chess, so
there is a reward if you are
going to kill one of the
opponents pieces and there is a
reward and there is a loss of or
there is a penalty if you lose
some of the your own pieces.
So essentially, based on the
rewards that that are going to
come out of these steps, the
machine is going to learn how to
perform the activity.
So the same thing applies when
when a robo has to travel
through a a hazardous June.
OK, so this is a.
This is possibly a example taken
from one of the websites.
That website is given.
So supervised, unsupervised and
reinforcement, the
differentiation.
And and I hope by now I do not
need to explain.
I was hoping that if by now the
point is not clear, we can
understand what is the
difference between typical
people who are going to look at
reports who are going to create
aggregates and create MIS
reports and create a lot of
create clots from the data
within the database.
So what exactly is the response?
The difference between what they
do and what what data scientists
often does.
So I had a question that the
what is the difference between
Yes.
the labeled and unlabeled data?
As we mentioned in the last
slide.
OK, OK.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, OK.
OK, labeled and unlabeled data,
I'm going to I'm going to tell
you.
So suppose that suppose that we
have data.
About, let's see.
Let's say we have the.
Let me go back again since we
talked about an example.
So we have a data you are a
part, a data scientist in a team
which is trying to predict which
party is going to win the
election.
So you have a complete voter
list for the constituency, but
then you have only done survey
and then you think that the
constituency has about 3,00,000
people and you have done survey
with about 3000 people and for
those 3000 people you think that
you know whom they are going to
vote for based on because though
The thing is that the voting
that they do is secret but you
believe that they give you a
true answer to you or does that
answer your question?
Who has asked the question?
Yes, yes, Sir.
Yes.
Right, Mr evil?
So what we are saying is that
these 3000 elements are labeled
samples labeled in data elements
or labeled data objects or data
records and the remaining
2,97,000 data objects or data
records that you have they do
not have a label.
Focus on this, yeah.
Alright so.
Uh yes, Mr VENKATRAMAN, that is
correct.
You know the output, assuming
that the label is the most
important thing.
Yes, you know the output.
Now let us look at a little
understanding of what is the
data in enterprise.
So this maybe you are some of
you may be very comfortable but
then it makes sense that we talk
about it at the in the
introduction session so so any
enterprise you have lot of data.
So today we have a lot of data
to the enterprises have lot of
data.
And Dominion Enterprises are
keen on data driven.
Decision making.
They're keen, at least that is
how we see, at least in the
records or the reports.
So now, now let us see what is
the type of data that they have.
Uh, so big it can be.
They may have structured data,
so typically the structured data
most popular repository for
structured data is RDBMS.
Which stores the data in a
tabular form, so it tabular form
is.
So so now we are saying uh, the
age.
Qualification and designation.
So maybe we can have an employee
ID.
So what we have done is that we
have created tabular data.
Each row is representing one
employee and it is going to give
that employee details and RDBMS
are best suited for storing such
data and we have a lot of data
that is being generated which is
of the form JSON or XML.
So this is often referred as
semi structured data.
So where this structure is not
strongly defined like an RDBMS,
but structure is approximately
defined in the sense that each
record has some structure.
But there is some variation
between the record to record
with respect to the structure.
Then there is unstructured data.
There is a lot of unstructured
data and this includes so all
text.
Multimedia.
So there is a lot of data that
is being generated today
nowadays, which is going into
the unstructured data and it is
growing very fast.
So today, if you look at a
typical organization, they may
not have even 10% structured
data and it is possible that
what they have is a 90% is
unstructured data or maybe even
more so.
So let us take again.
We'll go back to the one example
we had talked about some time
back, which is a bank.
So now for bank.
What is the structured data?
So it can be employees of the
bank, it can be the customers of
the bank.
It can be the accounts of the
balance.
They are all representing
structured data.
They're not going to have a
identical structure for each one
of them, and they're going to
store the columns and their
values and the tabular form, and
then they can do perform many
operations on that, then semi
structured.
Suppose that there are many
banks which need to exchange
data because there are many
times at least the check
processing and fund transfer
which keep happening between the
bank to bank.
So they need to do a
reconciliation between the
banks.
So now it is possible that not
all banks will have the same
identical systems.
And even if even if they use
identical technologies, they
design of the system will be
different.
So in one bank, the account may
store some 50 attributes and in
another bank they may store 65
attributes.
So it is possible that there can
be different set of attributes
that are stored and then the
meanings of the attributes can
also be different.
So when they try to exchange the
data for the respect to the
interbank transactions, so they
need to depend on what is
generally XML exchanges, that is
what they do.
So the XML or JSON exchanges
will help them decode the data
that the other bank has sent
that they need to.
So now unstructured data.
So can somebody tell me what is
the unstructured data that the
bank may have?
Customer feedbacks.
Customer feedback.
It may also be structured, but
it may be unstructured.
I agree with you.
Yes, because sometimes they mean
right, yes.
Customer photo photo.
Excuse me. Don't talk.
Go to their signature digital
signatures they make.
Signatures.
Right.
Pictures.
Yeah, voice stream.
Pictures, right?
Yeah.
Can you repeat?
Can you repeat the voice thing?
Is that voice stream?
Yeah.
Voice recordings.
Yes, yes, right.
What more?
Here we see dogs.
Everything goes.
Yes.
So there are many images and
many images that they need to
Yes.
So there aren't many images.
keep and for example they are
also expected to keep a video
recording of or the ATM's or the
branch.
What happens right and it is
possible that the law
Chat with chat with customer
support.
enforcement agency may say that
you need to keep the video
recording for the last six
months because if any report is
there or any any compliant is
there, so they need they
possibly wants to go back,
correct.
So all such data is unstructured
data.
So now you can tell based on
what we discussed.
So what is the what is likely to
be the percentage of the banks
structured data?
This will be much smaller than
the video recording that they
have to store because they they
may have to.
A A refer back for some law
enforcement or for some other
reason for some other reason.
Also, they may go back and they
may have to check the videos so
so the point is audio
recordings, right?
That is right, as you pointed
out.
Or you recordings legal
documents, chat logs, yes,
emails, images.
Absolutely.
So so you are bringing in so
many examples where which they
may have want to store and some
of those multimedia may be very
heavy and me required lots and
lots of in a huge site huge
site.
So when you have so much data,
so now now you maybe you may
want to answer the next thing.
So the data may have a very
lying levels of return on byte.
So do you want to do anybody?
Does anybody want to comment on
the return on byte of various
data elements that we have
talked about for a bank bank is
something I think all of us
understand.
Second, no, repeat the question
return off.
Return on byte.
So suppose that you are storing
A1 MB for for some transaction.
But.
You are storing 1 GB for
something else, so one GB is
Yeah.
about 1000 * 1 megabyte.
So.
So The thing is that when you
compare this data based on
The structured data.
return on byte that one GB
should offer you 1000 times more
value for the bank in terms of
something maybe profit.
So if they want to manage the
data or if they want to think
about the importance of the
data.
So that means, like uh.
Even one KB of data is also more
important when we consider as a
transaction so.
OK, right.
That is correct, right?
Absolutely right.
Mr Mahendra Nath Reddy, what you
said is absolutely.
So ohh the arouser.
That means that the inside which
we are gaining by analyzing the
data in whichever method that
should be like a quantifiable.
It is.
See. See.
In fact, if you ask a CEO, CEO
will want everything to be
quantifiable, right?
Or do you have some doubts?
No, no, not that is correct.
OK, so the so the point is that
they will say that, OK, we have
spent $1,000,000 in deploying
areas, fancy data science
system, a machine learning and
some system and now now the
point is that what is the
increase in the enrollment of
customers, that is what the CEO
is going to say, right?
So last last quarter we have got
10,000 new customers.
So in this quarter, after after
incorporating a fancy machine
learning system, you got 9009
thousand customers.
You know the face of First EVO
will not be so good.
OK, so so the point is that the
return on byte Y I'm saying is
that not all data is equally
important.
For example, bank needs to keep
video recording of all its ATMs,
but then it is not going to make
any profit out of that.
So it has to do that because it
has to follow some regulation.
So it will do that.
It will do that, but then when
it comes to the analytics or
giving lot of focus, so it is
possible as one of Mr Mahendra
Nagar's pointing out the
transactions.
Believe they may focus.
For example, they may want to
find out which through which
customer they're making a lot
more profit than which other
customer, right?
So most probably they will be
interested in that type of
analysis.
So the point is that the data
has a written on white.
All we want to understand is
that all data is not equal.
Not much more, OK.
And then data me have a acid
property, largely acid
properties.
Talking about relational
databases, implement a property
called acid properties whereby
they guarantee that the
integrity of the data will never
be violated, and if multiple
people access the data, they're
all going to say they're
identical.
Feature.
But many times, for example, if
if you are working, if you are
frequenting social media so you
know that in social media,
suppose that you post a message
so you post a message and you
may call immediately your friend
in US.
That friend may not have seen
the message, even if the friend
is logged into social media,
they may not have set seen the
message, particularly if you're
posted a video or or picture you
call immediately.
They may not have seen it.
That is because it is not a.
Consistency is not so important
for setting data, so in that
case what we call is a base
property which is that eventual
consistency is good enough.
But as it property is immediate,
consistency is import and the
data may have another property
which is related to the velocity
where we may deal with the
stream of data and we may still
need to perform certain things
on some data may allow us to
perform in batch.
Ah, so can you give example of
AC property?
Acid property.
Suppose that you are
transferring money from your
You know.
account to another account of
your friend or or some vendor to
whom?
From whom you bought a product.
So you are doing a transfer in
both you and your vendor have
account in the same bank and
then when you are transferring
letter, say you bought a product
and transferring ₹5000 rupees to
your vendor.
So the acid property guarantees
that either both debit on your
account and the credit on your
vendor accounts both happen or
neither of them happen because
the communication link is back
or the gateway is back, or the
server crashed for any reason.
The ACID properties guarantee
that either the transaction
happens completely or does not
happen at all.
Thereby you stay inconsistent
state.
So if you are debited but your
vendor is not credited so that
they say that the database is
not inconsistent state.
Miss Surbhi, have I answered the
question.
Uh, yes, thank you.
All right then.
Then we are talking about
databases.
Databases may have two broad
categories, so our RDBMS use SQL
for querying and they are
referred as SQL databases.
Presently, because we have large
number of no SQL databases, they
know SQL databases is a
phenomenon that is about 10
years old or not 10 years, maybe
15 years old, but then they have
caught up like anything and
today the no SQL databases are
offering significant or hosting
significant data of the
organizations and SQL still is
the IS for all the transactions.
So for example, you want to
operate a system which does the
funds transfer or you are
operating a system which is
doing a product sales.
Or if you are operating a system
which is doing a reservations,
or if you are doing a, let us
say trading in Stock Exchange
trading.
So in all these cases where the
consistency or the acid
properties are very, very
essential.
So in such cases they will go
with either RDBMS implementation
or they mean implement the
entire as RDBMS properties
through their own coding.
That is also possible.
And then then we have the no SQL
databases, no SQL databases.
Take various forms and one of
the important characterization
is that the no SQL databases can
be replicated to many locations.
If the RDBMS you replicate the
replication is going to
incorporate, put a lot of cost
because the consistency and
replication they are conflicting
demands and no skill databases.
They go with the base and
because of that what happens is
that they offer larger volumes
and they support the eventual
consistency and various forms of
and and generally the no SQL
database also come with a lower
license fees compared to RDBMS
because of the property, their
nature and.
And let's look at why go beyond
RDBMS.
So this is just an explanation
that we are looking at, yeah.
The I think we have already
talked about this.
So.
So The thing is that SQL it does
not scale very well and it is
not suitable for semi structured
data though today all the SQL
vendors claim that they are
hosting lake houses so they can
also store unstructured data.
So you go to any RDBMS vendor.
They say that, OK, we can store
unstructured data so, but then
they're not very effective or or
possibly it's a.
So just to store unstructured
data, you don't want to use
RDBMS.
So to combine unstructured data,
unstructured data, maybe use
RDBMS.
So these are the strengths and
weaknesses and this is a picture
that is giving you the ranking
of the various DBMS vendors over
the 10 year period.
And the URLs are given from
where you're going to this is
taken.
And you can see that now within
the top ten, you got a database
called MongoDB which is a no SQL
database.
So but if you go back ten years
ago, certainly there was no no
SQL database.
MongoDB existed at 19th place so
So what you can see is that many
more noise SQL databases such as
NEO 4J which started in 2017
Redis which started in 2018 and
so these all have started and
they have grown to a significant
market share in last few years.
These are all new Esquel
examples.
So we need to understand that an
organization may have an
organization will have many
diverse forms of data and I do
not think that I need to explain
because this is giving you a
list of diversity.
Examples of diverse data.
And maybe I will go or just
momentarily into a website just
to just to give you a feel of
this may not be very maybe many
of you are familiar, but I have
taken the example from AWS.
So all we are saying is that the
way they're looking at that data
architecture, so that includes
relational databases and then no
SQL databases which they call as
non relational databases and
they have data warehouse and
they have the algorithms et
cetera for processing the data
and they have logs which may be
simple flag files and they may
incorporate data leak.
The data leak is essentially
unprocessed data that they
receive from diverse sources and
which is not preprocessed but
kept in a leak.
So essentially it is receiving
and holding so that you can
process it at future as you
required.
So the there can be multiple
types of flows and they are
talking about inside out.
There can be a flow of data
leaked to various of forms of
this data and it is possible
that outside inflow may be
happening and it is possible
that from these six sources
there may be interexchange
between these six sources
between themselves and so on.
So this is giving you an
indication about the diversity
of the data that the
organizations boost and and I
think that this may be a good
time to take a break.
So one question, when the slave
that you showed.
Are you you are.
You have to speak louder.
Your voice is coming with a lot
of noise.
Jesus talking university.
It is still not so clear.
I'm I'm unable to for the uh get
the words.
OK.
So real time, yeah.
You you make type.
I I don't know.
Mr Mahendra Nath Reddy, whether
I have a 2023 graph, maybe I'll
have to check.
Uh, OK, alright.
So so I'm putting I'm I will
answer if Mr Babish CHANDRA's
answer question, maybe I will
answer it after the break.
So now let us take 5 minute
break.
Thanks that's.
OK, there are many questions.
So just I think, let's let us go
one by one.
So I'm seeing that messages.
Ohh OK SOMYA Prabal wants to
move to the weakness and
strength slide.
Uh, OK.
More than liquids, architecture
seem to unify this thing too.
Yeah, that is fine.
I I'm I'm fine that they are
trying to put them together and
in fact you we are what we are
seeing is a data architecture
proposed by AWS and you know
that AWS is very popular among
many organizations.
I'm not saying this is the most,
but then even the other vendors
must be offering a similar type
of structure, right?
That is already happening, Mr
Babish.
So because what we are seeing is
that there is a connection.
So unify means that there are
when there are multiple
technologies, you cannot unify
them.
For example, you can make unique
machine and Windows machine talk
to each other through
networking, and then you may
make them share a lot of files,
but they're not protocols for
sharing there.
But that doesn't mean that
unique and windows are going to
become one, right?
OK.
So Mr Mahendra Nath says that
yes, lot of integration
happened.
OK, fine.
And then Mr Sahil, Rajesh is
saying that.
OK, so fine, OHS, many services
and and then.
And then OK, there are some
comments about those comments,
OK and no skill supports ML.
That is fine, absolutely.
Today, if you go to Oracle or
Microsoft, they're going to say
that from their databases you
can perform all the EML tasks.
That is what they say, so it is
possible they provide you the
ways to do it.
Maybe you have to buy some extra
licenses and then then.
OK, fine.
I'm I'm not commenting on that
because let us not go so deep
into the each vendor, so that's
not really though I'm I
appreciate your putting the
you're sharing the knowledge but
we will not go into the specific
vendor and we are showing an
example of a WS that does not
mean that AWS architecture is
the best but we I have to choose
one I have to choose.
Alright, so now let us proceed
further.
Let us proceed further, alright.
So let us look at the let us
look at uh, like the data
science roles.
So what we will do is that so so
for the.
Uh, let me go to.
OK.
So let us look at some what one
of the vendors is proposing the
rules.
So in fact I can.
I'm going to show at two places,
so the University of Berkeley,
they're talking about, data
scientist, data analyst, and
then a data engineer.
And they're giving us the roles.
What is it?
The data scientists examine
which questions need answers
related to data, and they
require business acumen,
analytics skills and so on.
OK.
And data analyst is bridging the
gap between data scientists and
business analysts.
I hope that is self explanatory.
So they are.
They are better equipped to talk
to the business analysts or to
the management.
And then data engineer is more
technical.
Person is focused on
development, deployment,
management of data pipelines and
then similar thing is put in
terms of in this website also.
So they are trying to put it in
the form of a so data scientist.
And what is it that you can
expect from a data scientist?
What are the preferred skills
for the data scientists and then
a data scientist can be focusing
on machine learning or simply
data journalist?
I do not take it is essentially
focus.
More on front end or the back
end, and then they're talking
about data architect.
Data architect is there for
constructing the all the pieces
and putting them together and
then data engineer who is going
to implement the individual ETL
kind of skills and they need the
knowledge of SQL, No SQL and
then so on and they are going to
the they're essentially data
architect, has a vision and then
data engineer is possibly going
to implement it.
OK, I hope that gives a
reasonable understanding of the
rules.
Uh.
Uh, OK, OK.
I'm sorry one person is unable
to hear.
So, so OK, so I think the roles
and anyway there are many people
I'm little concerned about
talking too much about the rules
because in the organizations
they give the designations based
on various factors.
So they may call for a small
organization.
They may have a data architect
doing everything.
They may call that person a data
scientist, and that person may
have to do everything that is
related to data, whether it is
ETL or whether it is building a
building a proposing an entire
data architecture or or going to
create the UI or the visuals.
So they may have to do
everything so.
So The thing is, but then you
get a idea that what is the
type.
So the work that is involved and
programming is a must for data
scientist.
This is really a question.
So for example I I can tell you
because I have been, so it's a
I've been in industry for.
Very long time.
So so let me tell you something.
So there is always a culture it
it is pretty much an
organizational culture.
So, uh, when I was working in
the West, what I have seen is
that there are people at the age
of 60 years very keen on doing
programming and and then there
are there.
If you look in many of the data
software services organizations,
so it is possible that after 10
years of experience, the people
will be working only with
spreadsheets and probably with
the project management software
may not be doing programming.
So really there is nothing for
me to tell you what is required.
And now the question is data
scientist designation.
We have shown you what are the
skills, our expectations from
some of the things one is coming
from the University of Berkeley,
University of California at
Berkeley, and another one we are
we we have seen is which is
coming from one of the vendors
in this area.
So now whether how you want to
interpret?
I leave it to you anyway.
It is your organization which
tells what you should be doing.
Mr Virendra, have I answered
your question?
Because it's not for me to say
whether you should know Python
for all.
For all you know, your
organization says that use are
fine.
You you use are so now is our
higher level language or Python
is higher level.
I leave it to you because that's
it is possible that and then you
may have a different opinion and
somebody may say that, OK, you
may simply use a tool like a
vacca, and VACCA does not
require you to do programming.
You can do it everything through
drag and drop.
So now do you call that
programming and if you perform a
task using Weka, do you call
that you have done program?
So I I leave that those are all
those are all lot of HGH around
that.
OK.
But then we can see that what
are the broad skills that are
expected?
Alright, so I'll proceed
further.
So we will look at data science
activity examples.
So some of you have asked what
are the examples for
classification examples for
clustering?
So we'll go through them.
Ohh, at this point at this point
I just want to see everybody's
quite a maybe I'll continue
without my.
Maybe after another 15 minutes
or 20 minutes I will enable the
mic for everybody so that so
that we can interact if
required.
I hope that's fine.
So we have talked about, uh, the
supervised machine learning,
right, we are talked about.
And me and we have talked about
unsupervised ML.
We are going to see so the tasks
data science tasks that come
under this are referred as
classification.
And prediction.
Uh performed with the help of
regression unsupervised, often
the association.
And cluster.
And we'll see examples for each
one of them.
So classification is that given
a collection of records called
as training set training data
set, so record sets have
attributes and a class label
often referred as a label.
So when you have that we build a
model for those attributes that
are going to help you predict
the class label for previously
unseen records.
So now let us look at an
example.
So suppose that there is a tax
authorities, so tax authorities
every year receive millions of
tax returns and they want to
audit some of the returns.
Actually auditing can be a
costly process because they may
have to check through your bank
transactions.
They may have to check through,
they may even have to check what
are all the assets that you have
based on going through various
records, property records and
many other records.
So complete audit may be a very
expensive process, so they may
not want to do for all millions
of tax filings that happen every
year.
So they want to do select some
tax filings and then they decide
whether they should audit them.
So for that, let us say they
have been.
Ohh, they are seeing the tax
records for 100 years because
there are from hundreds of years
people governments are
collecting tax and in the past
also they wanted to collect tax
honestly.
So they are saying that they
are.
They are auditing the tax
records, at least for some
people and based on those
people, they are finding that
some people are filing their tax
returns.
Honestly, some people are
underreporting the income and
and then the government is
losing the tax revenues.
So you can have a class label,
so cheat is equal to no means
they are filing the tax return
properly with reporting the
proper reporting.
Yes, means they are under
reporting the income.
So now based on all the audits
that they have done over the
last 100 years, suppose that
they identified set and
attributes.
And the class label based on the
attributes.
So now using this data they can
create this is referred as
training data because for this
data they already know the
output because the IT department
is most concerned about the
people who are under reporting
the income.
So they know the class label who
are reporting their income
properly and who are not
reporting.
So now they can create a model
and based on the model they can
predict for these people whether
they are likely to have reported
the income properly or
underreported the income.
So it makes the job easy in
selecting the tax filings that
should be audited.
So is the example clear?
I hope the example is clear, so
that is giving you an example of
solving a classification
problems so that can help that
tax authorities.
So now let us look at a few more
examples.
So direct marketing, so this can
be one example, OK.
So direct marketing, what you
want to do know is that for
example, you are selling your
product.
So suppose that you are living
in Mumbai.
So Mumbai, I think has a
population of about more than
one crore.
Ohh honey I 10 million.
I think it is possibly 20
million people.
So you are trying to sell the
product to them, so you can't go
to every person in the 20
million people and then you are
going to give a brochure or
promote your product or do a
demonstration of your product.
So you want to identify the
likely customers who are going
to buy your product and then
that you are going to do based
on the similar task.
So you're going to identify the
attributes and you're going to
look at the data sets which are
indicating the people who bought
your products, and thereby you
are going to do a selective
target market.
On it.
I hope this is pretty much like
the previous example and we we
are all comfortable with this,
so this can be another example.
So it is possible that there are
millions of credit card
transactions that keep
happening, so it is possible
that by using certain attributes
of the type of the transaction
that is happening on the credit
card, looking at the history of
the transactions that you are
making.
For example, you have been
buying a a groceries and let us
say only groceries and
electronics and clothes for the
last 20 years.
You are a credit card customer
of the same company for the same
credit card you're using for 20
years and only three things that
you're buying either groceries
or clothes or electronics so
suddenly they notice that there
is a huge transaction for.
Uh for a weapon in some country
in Africa on your credit card.
So there is a they have a reason
to suspect, right?
So you are only going in
Hyderabad to your neighborhood
stores or to malls and you are
buying these set of products and
after 20 years they have
suddenly seeing that a
transaction happened in Africa
that and the person is and and
also buying a weapon.
So it is possible that it is a
fraud, so they want to predict
based on past history.
So similarly, the customer
attrition and Chun, so nobody
wants to lose their customer.
So behave based on the
transactions or based on
interactions with the customer
you want to predict.
Is it possible that this
customer is going to churn and
based on that you may offer
promotional some promotion or
find some way to retain the
customer because the getting a
new customer is expensive
process, so you want to make
sure that retain the existing
customers.
So this is again an application
for classification, then
clustering.
Let us go for clustering.
This is unsupervised machine
learning.
So what are we doing?
We have a set of data points.
There is no label.
And there are set of attributes.
And the using the attributes you
identify identify that there are
objects or data points data or
the OR the records victor
similar to one another and which
are less similar to one another.
And you make create the majors
to find out the distance and
similarity.
So we can take A and then let us
look at this data set.
So their intent of the
clustering is to identify from
this data set that there are
three clusters.
Such a dot, the intracluster
distance is minimum and
intercluster distance is
maximum.
So this is an example that may
help.
This is a I understand this is
100 year old example, so this
was a plot that was made by
physician John Snow in London
when there was an outbreak of
cholera, which is more than
about 100 years ago.
So by studying this map, the
Doctor could identify what type
of precautions and win which
area.
There is a large number of
vulnerable people and that may
have helped the Government of
London in containing the
casualities and and and then
optimizing their medical
resources.
So this we can consider as an
example of cluster.
And the clustering and
application can be market
segmentation.
So what we are doing is that we
are identifying the customers
and then based on set and
attributes and then we are
creating the grouping of the
customers.
So for example, for example a
bank, a bank.
And I'm picking the same
example.
If bank me want.
To establish.
Platinum.
Gold and the silver
relationships.
So the bank maybe having 10
million customers, there are
some banks in India which are
very large banks that may they
may have 10 million customers.
So the what they want to do is
that they want to use some
algorithmic approach whereby
they decide that platinum
customer.
Each serviced by general manager
and gold customer is many
serviced by manager and silver
customer.
It's serviced by executive.
Right.
So now what they want to do is
that they do not have any other
basis, but they need to create 3
clusters such that that
facilitates them in associating
the the bank at the customers
with the suitable relationship
manager.
Not much more.
So he had.
There is really no supervision,
but then they can consider many
factors.
For example, how many products
the person is using?
How much money we are making
from that and what is the
potential for making future
money so that is the more
important for bank.
So for example, you are a very
rich person, so even if you have
a small relation, the possible
that they want to connect you
with their general manager so
that the general manager can
bring you in or make you
involved in new products.
So.
So the point is that the
clustering is an unsupervised,
but is of course it has a
purpose and here is another
clustering which is a document
clustering.
So, so many organizations which
have been business for decades,
or even some organizations,
maybe in centuries, they will
have millions of documents and
it is possible that they're
digitized all the documents.
But then if you want to get
benefit out of those documents,
it is not possible for you to
read the document end to end.
It's not possible for anyone to
read the documents end to end
because that is going to take
away maybe 30 years of your time
and then you can't afford to do
that.
And the company doesn't want you
to do that.
So you need to find a mechanism
whereby you're going to group
the documents and so that you
will be able to find your
related or interesting document
easily.
So it is possible that the
cluster and then suppose that
I'm talking about in IT services
company.
I'm thinking a different example
so they are going to identify
which are proposals.
Which are contracts.
Which are architecture
documents.
And which are design documents
which are test plans.
So this this will help making
use of the documents but it is
not easy just to do that by
going manually do that do that.
So it is possible that you're
going to do a clustering based
on the similarity of the
documents, and after that you
maybe it may be able to find
that separate out the documents
into different types and even
possible that after you do that
clustering, you may even give a
label, for example the entire
universe universe.
We say that it is consisting of
many galaxies and we say that we
are living in a Galaxy that is
called Milky Way.
But then what is the definition
for it?
There is no definition.
All be the definition is very
simple.
The definition of galaxies and
the universe is coming.
Based on these two criteria,
nothing more.
But we say that we are living in
Milky Way but not in Andromeda,
right?
And now we're going to another
unsupervised machine learning,
which is called association.
So this is also sometimes it is
referred in some books as a
Market Basket analysis.
So Market Basket analysis is
that so we want to see the
association rules from the data.
So it is quite possible that a
person buying bread.
If a person buys bread, the
person will also buy butter.
It is possible, so it can be a
valuable pattern for the grocery
store owner, so finding such
patterns for particularly for a
ecommerce vendor who has got
million products, if they find
useful association rules, it may
enhance their business in a
significant way.
OK, there is a question from Mr
Virendra Kumar Singh saying that
what is the idea of distance in
cluster and in fact distance
between objects is again a
distance that we are going to
define using our own intuition.
So for example, you are, let us
say we are talking about the in
a bank in a bank.
Then suppose that there are
three criteria that we want to
use to create the distance.
One is the current the account
balance and one is that the
profit that the bank made from
the customer and the third one
is the income of the customer.
So now it is for the bank to
decide that.
What is the weight is they want
to give each one of them
depending on the weightage that
they give.
The distance computation will
change, Mr Virender Singh have
answered the question.
And of course it can be any type
of distance.
It can be Manhattan distance,
Euclidean distance.
We are going to learn about
various types of distances that
can be computed and, but then
the important part is that you
need to identify which are most
significant attributes which are
least significant attributes.
What is the type of?
The weight is that you want to
do.
So we are looking at the
association rules, so this is
describing the association
rules.
I hope I do not need to explain.
These are all simple terms, so
when you have a rule, you have
an antecedent and a consequent.
So this is the antecedent.
And this is consequent.
So nothing more and you may see
that there can be various
applications for this type of
patterns.
So for example, if you're
talking about, let us say the
type of a problem and the type
of the components that are
required.
So you are sending a service van
to service the customers and
then and then you do not have a
full idea about the problems
that they have to.
For example, you are sending
some service person he has to go
around and fix the problems with
the 10 television sets.
Order, order.
Maybe television sets?
I do not know whether people are
repairing now, but maybe we can
talk about some other a thing.
Let's say air conditioners OK
and then air conditioners.
That person has to service the
10 air conditioners in the day
and you think that there are
some components that are
required and you also have some
idea about the type of the
problems that they have
reported.
They cannot give you exact
statement of the problem.
They do not know.
So based on that, you may be
able to decide what are the
components that the service
person should carry, right?
And then beyond the Market
Basket analysis, you may also
find interesting sequential
patterns.
Sequential patterns are that
some event happened today, so
another event is likely to
happen later.
So if you have bought a bike
motorbike cycle from a
motorcycle from A1 of your
dealers in the city.
So if you bought that motorcycle
motorcycle on 25th of November,
they know that you will require
one liter of engine oil in May
of 2024.
So this is a sequential pattern,
so they you do not require
engine oil today, but they know
that if they had sold thousand
motorcycles today in me, they
know for sure that they will
require 1000 liters of engine
oil.
So this is representing a
sequential pattern, so
sequential pattern can have the
elements such as the gap, then
Windows sites that span and they
can be many problems, many
situations where the sequential
pattern will be helpful.
So each example has its own
domain meaning.
And we may have a problem such
as prediction.
So prediction is about trying to
predict the value of something
based on some inputs that you
have instead of a class label,
we are predicting the host.
So the very popular always
people quote is that I have in
apartment.
So so now I have see I have
locality idea, so the locality
I'm putting it as a high class
locality, middle class locality
or a or some simple locality.
So maybe I'll put two
categories.
One is a high class and the
possibly one and then two and
then one.
So the area is 1000 square foot
and then the price is 10 million
and then locality 2 this is 900
square foot.
And then let me see 6 million
and then locality one, I'm
talking about 800 square foot
and then the price is 7.5
million.
So now I'm trying to predict.
I have got a I'm seeing a new
apartment in locality one with
the area of 850 square foot.
So what should be the expected
price of that this problem is
called as a problem of
prediction and regression.
Is the method of solving.
Typically the prediction you are
predicting a continuous valued
variable.
OK, so this is similar to
classification where we were
predicting a label, but now we
are predicting a continuous
value and similarly we can have
a deviation or anomaly
detection.
This is also called as outlier
analysis.
So what we are doing is that
there is a website that is
serving a billion people and
there are few people who are
somehow for some reason they
have got intention that they
want to prevent that website
from functioning.
So they do some send some
messages using some lot of
technical analysis.
They send some messages which
caused the server to be
overloaded and thereby it is
unable to serve the remaining
customers.
So recognizing such intrusions
is a anomaly detection, or out
clear analysis, thereby lowing
such anomalies will help the
business a lot.
OK, now now I'm doing.
OK, I am enabling the mic for
people and I have.
OK, let me let me see.
There are questions from Mr
Aniruddha that athletic apparel
example of sequential pattern
similar to market bus.
Yes, S association rules and
sequential patterns.
They are similar.
It is only that association
rules focus only on
combinatorial elements and
sequential patterns.
Look at both combinatorial and
sequential elements.
So sequential pattern mining is
typically more complex than
association with mine.
I hope the the answer is.
Clear.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
Thank you.
OK, OK.
OK, so in that case I can
proceed to further.
So let us look, yes.
That can you sounds like.
Can it be like being that Market
Basket analysis that you were
saying?
Mr Aditya, can you repeat the
question?
Can you please explain the
Market Basket and this is that
you are saying?
Yes, yes, I can go back to that
slide and possibly spend few
more minutes. Yes.
Yeah.
Please.
Thank you.
So now we are talking about the
transactions that have happened
in a grocery store or say
supermarket.
So what we are saying is that a
customer walks in transaction ID
one.
The person buys these two items.
You can see that the person
transaction one, there are two
items that they bought and then
in transaction 2 that person
bought 4 items, transaction 3
and so on and so forth.
So based on this data, they can
formulate association rules
saying that the person who is
buying diaper is very likely to
buy butter.
So don't, don't try to find out
the logical reasoning or
connection between the items or
this is possibly something you
can understand easily.
The person who is buying bread
is also buying the button, so by
formulating this type of rules
and then of course we need the
metrics to find out which rule
is good, which rule is strong?
Which rule is weak?
And so on.
And which rule is valuable?
Which rule is interesting?
We we want to find all those
things that we look at later on,
but finding these rules is
giving insights that are helpful
for the owner of the
supermarket.
Does that answer your question
or clarify the association rule?
Yeah.
So we are not building any
algorithm here.
We are framing rules.
No, no, we didn't use an
algorithm.
We will use an algorithm, but we
are not discussing the
algorithm.
Now we are only telling what is
association.
OK.
So the example you are giving
for Market Basket analysis does
not comes under the prediction
regression because you predict,
right?
So if you buy this product.
No, no, it we don't call that
prediction because what what is
happening is that we are finding
association between the items
based on the data.
There is no supervision. Here.
We are taking the data as it is
and we are discovering the
associations Mr Karthikeyan, so
that is why it is not considered
supervised machine learning so.
OK.
So you may say that, OK, it is
helping you in something so.
It it may help you in doing
something.
For example, bread implies
butter, so it may mean that if
butter is running out, you may
know that the customers buying
bread will be suffering.
So maybe it is helping you some
way, but we don't call that
supervised machine learning for
whatever reasons is that.
So in this case, in this case
our algorithm will will just
learn from the rules.
Yeah, that is right.
Just learn from transactions
without looking for any label.
Understood.
OK, Mr Gaurav is asking what is
regression model?
See regression model is there to
solve the problem of prediction
the prediction.
I hope you understood.
I have taken the example of
predicting the price of an
apartment, so let us say there
are only two attributes, one is
locality and the other is area.
We are trying to predict based
on the data that we have.
Mr Gaurav, is that clear?
Regression is a model that we
study later.
Prediction is the problem.
I hope that is OK.
OK, so now we will spend few
minutes on data science process.
So we are we are we have only 10
minutes so but fine we will
spend as much and then we will
continue in the next class
whatever overflow is.
So data science is really,
really significantly had a
cousin in software development
in the sense that ultimately you
have to develop software.
When you say machine is
learning, let us not forget that
the programs are written by
humans.
So machine is supporting by
studying the data and is helping
you giving the hints with
respect to the decision making.
But then the programs are still
written by the machine and the
bare metal machine is actually
is a brute waiting to be
trained.
So so we have lot of software
running on the machine and the
software either you wrote, wrote
or somebody else wrote but then
it is it is a software that is
facilitating.
So in that sense, the data
science also has to take some
inspiration or some learning
from these software engineering.
So in software engineering, we
can have the process models for
developing software.
OK.
So we are talking about some
examples of process models.
So one is waterfall model, one
is iterative model and other is
agile model for developing
software.
I hope you people are clear, but
then the idea is that so.
So the idea is that this is this
is helpful.
Helpful for complex problems.
With longer cycles.
And this is this is helpful for
a rapid development.
So the problem may be complex,
but what you did is that you
started breaking down the
problem and you also realized
that incremental gains can
happen if you start implementing
small part of the problem and
step by step you enhance the
solution.
So then you will go for a more
of an asylum.
So the data science process also
has many of the things which
required, for example,
understanding the problem in
software engineering.
It is called analysis.
Developing the model, this can
be coming under, so possibly
what you may say is
construction.
Or you may call with multiple
names, such as architecting,
designing, coding, and there can
be so there can be many phases
and then applying the model on
data set to see how it works.
This is often testing.
Alright.
And then deployment as it is
like in software engineering.
So there are data science
processes which have got lot of
similarities, but there are also
differences because data science
process as we see that involves
lot of getting the data right.
So that is very important part
of the data science process.
So in that for that region he
the many people from many
industries have come together
and developed a process called
crisp DM, which is helpful in
building the systems that are
essentially data science
solutions.
So here we need to understand
the business.
We need to understand the data
and we need to prepare the data
and then we need to model and
then after we do the model, we
evaluate and we go back.
Essentially we are iterating.
OK, so we are iterating these
steps and at some point we are
satisfied and we do the
deployment.
So.
So what we see is that if you
want to elaborate further, each
one of these phases, so you see
that Chris has six distinct
phases and each phase has got
several tasks.
So I think the tasks are mostly
self explanatory.
So you can see that the first
phase which is with respect to
which is with respect to the the
business understanding.
So it is pretty much like we are
trying to do what many times
people do as a SRS software
requirement specification or
business analyst is going and
talking to the to the users and
is creating the stories so that
you start implementing the
stories.
So the point is that many of
that similar things you need to
do, but then your focus is
different, that is you go, you
have a lot of data and you want
to gather insights, but then the
insights are valuable only if
you understand what is the
business, what is valuable for
the business.
And then did not many steps that
you need to perform with respect
to the data preparation.
So that involves the
understanding that data quality
and then preparing the data.
So these are many of these steps
are referred as a preprocessing
in some terms, so I'm going to.
All I'm saying is that you, me
here.
Many words many times.
So somebody may say
preprocessing and some author
may say that you are doing
feature engineering.
And some mortars may say that
you are doing ETL, you have to
do before you build the model.
So so let us not be overwhelmed,
but we understand that there are
several steps that need to be
performed before you start
constructing the model.
Alright.
And that then once the model is
dead, we need to evaluate the
model.
How do we evaluate the model we
are going to run it on some new
data for which we know what is
the expected output and we are
going to see is it giving the
output as expected or is it
giving distinctive and then we
want to go back and analyze if
the model is something that
Gartner calls interesting
expectation from today's system
is explainable AI.
So they're saying that the
deeper understanding you get
from the of the model you you
have a greater confidence in
them.
OK, I think I will not.
This is the so maybe I will take
a minute to go through this
document which is the crisp
evaluation, which is a recent
document which is done by the
data science process aliens,
which says that presently about
half of the data science
projects mostly go with this.
That is their survey that they
had done in 2020.
OK.
And then they explained the
same.
And they also talk about what
are the strengths and weaknesses
within the crisp DM so that you
need to take care.
So I'm stopping at this point.
I'm just waiting if there are
any questions I will take,
otherwise I will close the
session.
So ohh.
Thank you, Sir for the.
Book.
OK.
OK, what is?
Yeah.
So thank you, Sir.
Classification is supervised
machine learning.
Clustering is unsupervised
machine learning, so
classification requires training
data.
Clustering is on the data, so it
is not having anything called
training data have a answered or
am I confusing you more?
And I think the examples of the
problems are also given.
Uh, OK, I will go back to maybe
the example will help you.
So classification example, each
checking which customer is
likely to buy the product OK
classification example is that
As.
you have a product and you want
to know which customer will buy
and clustering is that you have
got.
You have got many.
You have got many people and
then you want to group them into
separate categories so that it
may help you in doing the
business operations.
You do not have anything else.
Uh.
Having answered summer Karthik,
you can speak actually.
I'm really jumping the gun, but
a new validate a clustering
Got.
algorithms output.
Yes, yes, we will study that.
It is not easy, but then we will
study that we will study few
methods.
That we will study little later.
OK?
OK, Mr Raja.
Anti Lal is asking what will be
the exam like.
See the exam will be something
which is, uh, which will have if
you want.
If I put it in simple check the
concepts and the apply.
So both of them we will check.
So you may have to solve some
numericals.
You may have to explain certain
concepts, but then we will talk
a little about examination.
But then the course is not
really only for examination
anyway.
If anyway, you will prepare for
the examination, no problem.
But the we have to facilitate
the learning first, right?
OK, Mr SAURABH Gautam is asking
upload the document, yes, yes,
the slides will be uploaded.
Yes, and the anyway this session
is getting recorded.
Alright, OK.
If there are no other questions,
we will close the session.
Thank you, Mr crap.
Thank you, Sir. Bye.
Yeah.
Cancel.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.